what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
Channel all right so for our classic DC
Video I was trying to figure out you
know what what topic I was going to do I
was trying to figure out what video I
was going to cover because we did Crisis
on infinite Ur already so it's like well
where do you go from there where do you
go from crisis on infinite Ur it's like
the definitive you know DC story it
helped to define the company in the
1980s and really for the entire 20th
century you know they came out of
nowhere I mean they came out just just
guns blazing you know it was it was nuts
when it happened and so uh I figured we
try elseworlds we try an elor story now
this is the one about how basically
Batman and the Justice League become
Green Lanterns now uh for those of you
guys who are veterans to elseworlds in
DC because I know there's a lot of you
guys that know a lot about DC Comics
bear with me for a second because
there's a lot of people who don't so in
DC Comics elseworlds are very similar to
Marvel's what if the difference between
these two things are the bases behind
their creation so if we took a character
like Wolverine for example there is a
story called well was really called like
what if Wolverine Enemy of the State but
I just called it what if Wolverine
killed the Marvel Universe because a lot
more people will watch a video with that
title but in that original story in the
main marel timeline Wolverine had been
brainwashed by the hand in Hydra and had
gone on a campaign of killing off the
heroes the difference is that in the
main Marvel timeline wolver rain had
been captured by The Avengers and the
brainwashing had been reversed the what
if story was what if the brainwashing
hadn't been reversed that's how most
what if stories work they just Branch
off from the main Marvel timeline in DC
else worlds aren't really that way
they're just stories out there we don't
really know anything about the universe
aside from whatever the story happens to
give us we don't know if it's the exact
same we don't know if it branches off we
don't really know exactly how things
progress and in a lot of instances the
elor stories will basically pick up with
the beginning of a character from their
earliest days and then just give give us
a story and so it's really
self-contained in a lot of different
ways now with regards to this particular
story what we do is we initially pick up
with Batman and what this tells us is
that this is basically uh instead of
Bruce Wayne becoming Batman he becomes a
Green Lantern of course with the Batman
Mythos uh it's really kind of like a
main stay of his character that he goes
to this sort of crisis of conscience
after his training after his experience
he sits down and says I have to find a
way to save Gotham I've got to find a
way to restore this this city to the way
that it used to be and then eventually
he just rests on becoming a bat instead
this doesn't happen in the moment when
he's supposed to see a bat when a bat
was supposed to fly through the window
when it was supposed to strike his
imagination and lead him to becoming
Batman instead he receives a message
from abensur who crash lands on earth
now this is almost identical to the
original how Jordan Green Lantern Mythos
right in the sense that abensur had
crash landed on Earth and it you know he
had had his ring go out choose a worthy
host and it ended up grabbing Hal Jordan
instead it grabs Batman now of course or
I guess it grabs Bruce Wayne we we have
to stop calling him Batman in this video
it grabs Bruce Wayne and so initially it
shows him what it is that the ring is
capable of it shows him where he needs
to go to find abensur and it says here's
what you will become if you choose to
take this ring if you choose to be a
Green Lantern and so ultimately we join
uh Bruce Wayne and uh and Alfred as they
travel to where eansor is at and evur
basically says here's your duty here's
your job you know your job as a Green
Lantern is to protect this sector from
those individuals who would seek to do
it harm and your job is to guard the
entire sector not just your home planet
and so initially Alfred says well hey
maybe we should tell people what's going
on and Batman says no he says we're
going to give abensur a proper burial uh
and then we're going to take this ring
and we're going to be heroes because for
Bruce Wayne this is like the sign right
you know I mean this is this is like the
the the main DC continuity equivalent to
him seeing the bat and deciding to
become Batman instead he becomes a Green
Lantern now of course we get the Green
Lantern oath and no video no video
featuring The Green Lantern would be
complete without the oath so we're going
to do two things here the first is we're
going to run over this in Brightest Day
and darkest night no evil shall Escape
my mind let those who worship evils
might beware my power Green Lanterns
light that's one of the things that I
learned from comic storan videos on the
Green Lantern is you have to say the
oath you can't leave the oath out you
can't be like and then he said the Green
Lantern oath moving on like you can't do
that now here's the other thing your
assignment those of you in the robore is
to give us the Rob cor an oath post it
down in the comment section now I will
choose the winner and the winner gets to
decide next week's classic DC Video
having said that with Batman under I
guess having said that huh editor leave
that blip in there having said that with
Bruce Wayne taking over the mantle of
the Green Lantern the first thing he
does is he encounters the Red Hood now
again this is DC telling us here's the
early days of Bruce Wayne because in
virtually all instances of the the
traditional Batman Origin the Red Hood
is the first villain Batman comes across
now this is really rooted in uh some of
it's really pre-crisis some of it is in
the original Batman I think year one
story by Frank Miller but it was really
expanded on with the whole Killing Joke
by Alan Moore really set the stage for
like the Red Hood being the definitive
element of the Joker because if you go
by The Killing Joke as the origin of the
Joker then that tells us who he was
before he became Joker and so uh this is
really just kind of like a classic
instance of the Batman Mythos you'll
find the Red Hood somewhere in every
single origin story of Batman uh ever
since the Red Hood became a concept in
DC Comics instead of Bruce Wayne of
course showing up here as Batman and
facing off against Red Hood he shows up
which is actually pretty cool in in a a
cape and cowl with a Green Lantern form
now to be honest with you guys this
actually looks pretty badass but the
other half of this is that it seems as
though this prevents the entire Joker
situation from happening because keep in
mind the Joker came into existence
because of the conflict between himself
and Batman in the sense that this
unnamed man ultimately uh got into a
conflict with Bruce and Bruce knocked
him or I guess he fell into the chemical
vat by accident and then became the
Joker that doesn't happen here instead
because he has the power of the Green
Lantern he just rounds him up he rounds
him up he rounds up his henchman of
course there's a huge explosion but
they're saved from the explosion Now red
hood tries to get away and Batman takes
him and then he's just thrown in jail
and so in this instance in this elw
story The Joker just never really seems
to come into existence now uh following
his first Escapade which is usually part
for the course whenever a Green Lantern
is inducted into the Lantern core by
someone else who passes their ring on
it's usually like an act you know to to
demonstrate what it is that they're
capable of a lot of times it's the
Guardians of the universe watching them
and then suddenly the Guardians of the
universe manifest and say you need to
basically go perform this task for us
now not every Green Lantern agrees with
it and in this instance Batman or I
guess Bruce Wayne Batman Bruce Wayne Uh
doesn't like it and the reason why is
because for him he's a Green Lantern but
his goal is to uh is basically to
protect the Earth um he doesn't really
look at the entirety of the sector as
something to monitor instead he just
sees him as Earth superhero now of
course as we know with a Green Lantern
you kind of have to put the sector
before your own Planet your own Planet
really holds like a special place and so
more often than not with Green Lanterns
they'll keep a special eye on their own
Planet but most lanterns will protect
protect their entire sector now what
Bruce Wayne is told is that within his
sector there is a guy named Sinestro a
Green Lantern who's fallen from Grace so
this is where DC ties into the original
Sinestro Mythos but something I want you
guys to keep in mind is this story is in
1994 so this is you know 12 years or I
guess 10 10 or 12 years before uh Jeff
John's starts his Green Lantern Mythos
and so we don't have all the history of
sinestra that we have right now there
are no entities when it comes to the
lantern rings Parallax is not an actual
entity instead uh there's still the
concept of the weak winess to the color
yellow for whatever reason it's still
the idea that Sinestro just decided to
become a villainous dictator of his
Planet instead of the redcon that we've
seen recently where he took over kuger
in a dictatorial fashion because he
wanted to make sure his daughter grew up
in a reasonable environment and so of
course Bruce Wayne immediately sets off
you know at the request of the Guardians
and comes face to face with Sinestro now
again the Sinestro is no joke here but
remember this is Bruce Wayne this is not
Hal Jordan and so Bruce Wayne has
Intelligence he has guile he has combat
tactics he's very capable in his
abilities and so he's really very much
like an assassin with a Green Lantern
ring going against Sinestro and so this
fight isn't necessarily one-sided so
much as it's it's pretty even you know
just because of the fact that Bruce
Wayne has the combat prowers and the
wherewithal to go toe-to-toe with
Sinestro now the reason why this really
strikes Bruce Wayne strikes a cord with
him is because in his mind he sees very
much of Joe Chill in Sinestro and
that'll actually become a pretty
significant point of the story and the
sense of Mind melding and so on and so
forth but the idea is that in Bruce
Wayne the way he sees things Joe Chill
killed his parents because Joe Chill was
looking to solve a particular issue he
was a man on hard times and he just
ended up shooting Bruce Wayne's parents
because they had what Joe Chill wanted
at that particular moment in this
instance he sees Sinestro as a guy who's
just become mad with power and Sinestro
wants to maintain that power regardless
of who gets hurt in the process and so
Batman's or I guess Bruce Wayne's
initial thought is you know I'm not
going to worry about whether or not we
call him Batman for the rest of this
video whatever he's Green Lantern man
we're just going to call him Batman so
so Batman makes a call and says okay
look look this guy needs to come down as
fast as possible now here's the ironic
thing about this is once he defeats
Sinestro once he turns sinestro's
offenses against him and takes him out
the people within the planet kuger turn
on Batman and say why did you do this
like why did you why did you take him
out he was our provider yes he did some
pretty unsavory things but he gave us
everything we needed to survive he was
the guy that kept us going and they
looked to Bruce Wayne as the person that
will take them back to the life that
they're used to now this raises some
very important philosophical questions
in terms of the life of people and how
they perceive their own bondage as
something they would willingly Embrace
for the sake of having a simple life it
doesn't mean they're right or wrong it
simply just means these are the kind of
people that Bruce Wayne's running into
as the Green Lantern now of course while
this happens another woman steps up and
says why would you do this like you've
been you've been removed from the from
the Yoke of Oppression under the rule of
Sinestro and now you want to go back
she's like no no no no do not do that
you know you have freedom here you have
the ability to to to carve out your own
niche in the world to make your own way
go live your own lives and in response
to this Batman says okay these guys are
going to need guidance right I mean
they're going to need direction they're
going to need someone to show them uh
the right way to live so they don't
devolve back into a dictatorial
leadership or anything like that and so
he makes this woman a Green Lantern and
we learn This Woman's name is uh is
katat now I may be mispronouncing that
last name I have a terrible habit of
doing that but she's a well-known Green
Lantern in the uh in the Jeff John's
Mythos and so this is really I guess
really even before the Jeff John's
Mythos in terms of the Green Lantern uh
AR overall the Green Lantern uh Mythos
itself she's well known among the ranks
and so it's really just kind of DC
saying hey look these characters that
you know from the Green Lantern history
they're there you know they're they're
all still there you know they're just
playing different roles from what you're
used to now following this Batman takes
his leave and travels over to the to the
main Green Lantern court itself but this
is where we really start to see that
Batman doesn't necessarily see eye to
eye with the Guardians of the universe
themselves more so than that Batman
doesn't concern himself with cander and
we know that from his character in
almost every iteration where Batman's
ever existed he he's blunt he's straight
to the point he doesn't have time to
dilly dally and deal with political
correctness and that's what happens here
for him yeah the Guardians of the
universe gave them the power of the
Green Lanterns but they're just
Guardians why would the Guardians choose
Batman to be an adequate Green Lantern
if they didn't trust him to do the right
thing and so he doesn't really regard
them with like the utmost respect
instead they're simply just people who
gave him the ability to secure the
safety of his sector and this really
comes to uh comes to a head when he
initially gets into a debate with one of
the other Green Lanterns Tomar Ray now
of course we know Tomar to be a
well-known member of the lantern Corp
probably one of the most recognizable in
terms of just his physical appearance
but the idea here is that he's basically
brought uh Sinestro to the to the Green
Lantern Corp for him to stand Justice
now this follows very much with the
original Green Lantern Mythos with
regards to how Jordan when he first met
and battled Sinestro in the sense that
Sinestro is found guilty for abusing his
power as a Green Lantern and he
sentenced to life on cord now this is
where where things also get a little bit
different and the reason why I say that
is because he's basically given a
sinestra ring or yellow ring by the
weaponers of cord now as far as I'm
aware when Sinestro originally popped up
in the the DC Mythos before crisis on
infed Earth he was a green lantern that
was banished to cord and then ultimately
he ended up creating a Yellow Lantern
ring of his own accord with assistance
from the weaponers but they didn't
really like give it to him now I could
be wrong about that I may very well be
and I'm sure those of you who were well
versed in Green Lantern can probably
correct me on that but the fact remains
here that after defeating sestra we
basically follow Bruce Wayne when he
goes back to Gotham now this shows us
our first introduction to Commissioner
Gordon and this is a big deal this is
actually a huge deal and the reason why
is because when Batman first showed up
Commissioner Gordon didn't fully trust
him I mean you know Commissioner Gordon
was really uh I wouldn't say he's a guy
that walks you know the straight and
narrow but he was certainly a guy that
had ethics he was a guy that wouldn't
really involve himself in criminal
elements but when he sees Batman or when
he sees you know Bruce Wayne with a
Lantern ring of course not knowing his
identity of Bruce Wayne Uh commissioner
Gordon's initial response is this guy
just has way too much power now the way
that he says that or the way he reveals
this is during his time on Earth uh
Bruce Wayne Wayne has basically you know
stopped crime or stopped a huge element
of crime in Gotham City but he's done it
through fear he's done it through
criminals being afraid of the power that
he has as opposed to any almost any
other means that he uses now the kicker
with this is that he does the exact same
thing as Batman you know as Batman in
the main DC continuity he inspires fear
in people that's his thing you know
that's his stick when we were talking
about Nightwing and the rise of raptor
story arc we had talked about how the
difference between Raptor and Batman was
that Raptor thought it wasn't just
enough to scare people you had to be
willing to kill them as well now
where're Bruce way uses fear as Batman
the difference here is that Batman is
very much powerless in terms of having
Godlike abilities Batman's nowhere near
on the level of Green Lanterns Superman
in terms of sheer abilities instead his
greatest asset is his mind and that's
what he uses to topple a multitude of
different opponents I mean he's also got
like an insane amount of money and he's
got all kinds of cool gadgets but the
idea here is that Bruce Wayne being a
superhero operating as a superhero in
Gotham City with so much power as a
Green Lantern has not only instilled
fear in criminals is also instilled fear
in Commissioner Gordon and so you know
Bruce says hey look you know I have a
favor to ask I know you don't want to do
it but this is really the first step to
Commissioner Gordon understanding what
Batman's about with you know as a Green
Lantern and what his motives are and he
says I need to know the identity of a
guy of a man who had killed two people
um in an Alleyway you know 20 something
years ago now this is where the the the
mixed bag of Joe Chill comes into play
in DC Comics Joe Chill is universally
known as a guy that killed Bruce Wayne's
parents that's the role he's always
played you know in every single origin
story in every single redcon Joe Chill
appears as a guy that killed the parents
of Bruce Wayne the difference here is
that what happens after changes in this
story he basically at least it seems
like he became a cop and so the the the
idea is to trace this back and
eventually find out who this guy was uh
that shot the parents of Bruce Wayne now
from here we joined with the arrival of
Sinestro as we traditionally know him
with a Yellow Lantern ring but he
actually kills Commissioner Gordon now
this is a big deal because now
Commissioner Gordon is out of the
equation which means that we basically
have a situation whereby the Green
Lantern can't rely on the police because
that was always a thing you know Batman
being able to rely on the police was
just as much for his benefit as it was
for theirs he would bring them criminals
that they couldn't normally access
through you know conventional means and
he would be able to stay one up on the
the criminal element that goes on within
Gotham City but with uh with Sinestro
killing Commissioner Gordon we then
switch over to uh to Joe Chill now the
arrival of Joe Chill or I guess you know
Jo chill answering the door comes with
the arrival of Sinestro who's disguised
as a younger version of Bruce Wayne now
of course he makes his appearance as the
actual Sinestro but instead you know
instead of simply just uh just killing
Joe Chill what Sinestro says is he needs
to know how it was that Bruce Wayne's
parents were killed Sinestro was already
able to put two and two together he
knows that the Green Lantern is Bruce
Wayne what he needs to know is how to
get to Bruce Wayne and so over the
course of you know of after killing
Commissioner Gordon he had studied his
papers and realized that all this Trail
really LED back to Bruce Wayne becoming
uh the Green Lantern because of his
parents' death and so if someone killed
his parents and inspired him to take
this kind of an action then it would be
easy to manipulate that and so that's
what Sinestro does he basically absorbs
the mind of Jo chill and so now he's got
two minds in his own but he's also able
to take this war directly to Batman and
uh presumably use the death of his
parents as a means to uh to engage him
in in conflict and so that's really what
happens we get this weird sort of battle
that takes place over the course of
Gotham City where uh where Batman seems
to be able to overcome Sinestro right
you know it seems like he's able to to
initially take him out and so Sinestro
says okay fine you know if we lost
Batman if he was able to get away then
what we need is we need allies we need
people that can work on our behalf that
can take out this guy and so what he
does is he travels to the uh to the
residence of Harvey Dent and he
basically injures Harvey Den in such a
way that it it basically turns him into
two-c it makes him the two-c character
that we know in addition to this he also
grabs Carol Ferris who will go on to
become Star Sapphire and so the goal is
to basically rally these traditional
villains that we know from both the
Batman and the Green Lantern Mythos and
to Rally them under his under his own
cause and then turn them against Bruce
Wayne as Batman and it actually works
pretty well it works pretty effectively
now of course Batman is able to take out
both Star Sapphire and uh Twoface and
they basically Retreat to the uh to the
realm or to the the location of sestro
but what happens is Batman also comes to
the realization that if Sinestro was
using his Yellow Lantern ring to engage
in his own axe then instead of somebody
just trying to locate him by
conventional means he says we need to go
find him using unconventional means and
so what he does is he grabs the
satellites that orbit Earth and he
basically manipulates them or or changes
them in a way that they can detect the
color yellow in the emotional Spectrum
or at least what what passes for the
emotional Spectrum in the story in order
to basically seek out the effects of the
Yellow Lantern ring more or less tracing
radiation of the ring back to its source
the issue with this is that halfway
through this he's suddenly sought after
by the Guardians of the universe and the
Guardians of the universe say look you
need to go to rage War 4 you need to go
to this planet and you need to deal with
this conflict here where Bruce Wayne
says absolutely not this this is
ridiculous Sinestro is here on my planet
the people here on my planet could be
killed you know my fellow humans I'm not
going to abandon this place to whatever
Sinestro is doing because you want me to
go off somewhere else now the Guardians
say this is insane you cannot defy our
will like this and this is not the first
time this happened in the main DC
Universe we know that whenever a Green
Lantern defies the will of the Guardians
of the universe two things happen either
that Green Lantern goes Rogue and is
basically you know EXC communicated by
the core or they hand over their ring
and they give up being a Green Lantern
and a new Lantern's chosen in their stad
for Bruce Wayne he says look I'm going
to I'm I'm fighting Sinestro that's just
the way it is either you can send people
here and take my ring from me or you can
let me do this and so instead of
choosing one or the other the Guardians
of the universe split the difference and
what they do is they basically seek out
the greatest superheroes on Earth at the
moment they seek out Superman they seek
out Wonder Woman I guess hippo on
themira and they seek out the flash
Barry Allen and they say we're going to
make you Green Lanterns so that you can
basically round up and capture Batman
once he's defeated Sinestro or if he's
defeated Sinestro now in addition to
this they also have a contingency plan
you know because really the Green
Lantern is kind of like the contingency
you know they have the uh the Green
Lantern core that basically you know
that that goes against Bruce Wayne and
tries to round him up the kicker here is
that much like how Jordan in the
traditional Green Lantern Mythos Bruce
Wayne's the greatest of their of their
kind he's the strongest more C most
capable most Valiant and that makes
sense whenever it comes to the Green
Lantern Mythos the starring character is
always the greatest of them it wouldn't
make any sense to have the Green Lantern
Mythos revolve around how Jordan and
like you know killawog is the greatest
of them it would make sense that Hal
Jordan is the greatest of them because
Hal Jordan's the star of the title now
granted this also raises questions with
like the White Lantern Kyle rer you know
it brings into the equation Guy Gardner
John Stewart and a lot of different fans
of the Green Lantern latch onto their
own characters and so while how Jordan
may be the star of the show there are
people out there who will be like Guy
Gardner is the greatest Green Lantern so
I'm curious post who your favorite Green
Lantern is down in the comment section
because I really want to know because
I'm sure a lot of you guys are very
opinionated about this but the fact
remains that that Bruce Wayne's able to
easily break break out of their out of
their constraints break out of their
control and so during his time and
trying to figure out what's going on we
basically pick up with Sinestro and Toc
and Star Sapphire showing up in what
passes for the Batcave the reason why I
say what passes for the Batcave is
because this is not the traditional
Batcave because Bruce Wayne's not Batman
instead it's like the the lantern cave I
guess is the best thing to call it but
what happens here is is Alfred initially
tries to stop these guys he does the
best he can now this is one of the
really cool things is because
historically Alfred's always been like
one of the closest allies of Bruce Wayne
if not the closest it's the one guy that
Bruce Wayne could almost always trust
Alfred would lay down his line to
protect Bruce Wayne and the secrets of
Bruce Wayne and that's exactly what
happens here Alfred's attack by uh by
Sinestro and he's killed in the process
and so what happens is Sinestro sits
down and he says okay here's what's
going to happen right now the Guardians
of the universe sent the Green Lantern
core to capture Batman Batman will
probably get away from the Green Lantern
core but his ring is going to be without
a reasonable charge in the process he's
going to use a lot of the energy and so
what he's going to need to do is charge
his ring when he gets back here and so
he says what I'm going to do is is I'm
going to Ambush him in the process and
I'm going to weaken his central power
battery when this happens uh we're
suddenly met with the arrival of the
flash berry Allen Wonder Woman and
Superman who are now members of the
Green Lantern Corp and this is Beast
this is absolutely amazing to see them
part of part of the Green Lanterns but
the idea is that again Batman's
basically trying to fend off against the
lanterns on his own and so it's really
just two battles happening in two
different locations the kicker here is
that this is Superman as we know him
this is Wonder Woman as we know her this
is the flash berry Allen as we know him
they're every bit as powerful as a
character that we're used to and so
where you know Twoface has been imbued
with these solar Powers with these
abilities you know of of Sinestro in
order to fend off against Batman with
the Green Lantern ring and where Star
Sapphire is able to hold her own the
idea here is that they really can't
stand against Wonder Woman and the Flash
and Superman who were imbued by the
powers of the Green Lanterns and so what
happens they basically just drop the
bomb on them I mean they they show up
and they make quick work out of Sinestro
out of uh out of too faace and out of
Star Sapphire now what also happen
happens here is that this massive
explosion Alfred surviving for a couple
seconds and summoning Batman before he
actually dies results in Bruce Wayne
suddenly just taking off and running
over to the location of where Alfred's
at and so in his final moments you know
he basically sort of Pays His respects
his best he can but by the time Bruce
Wayne gets there Alfred has already
passed away Alfred's already dead and so
for for Bruce Wayne this is an
Incorruptible offense this is something
that he just cannot let go of Sinestro
has effectively killed everyone that he
loves now Sinestro didn't kill the
parents of Bruce Wayne but within the
within sinestro's mind is Joe Chill and
so to Bruce Wayne they're one and the
same person now you know the The Joe
Chill side killed his parents the
Sinestro side killed Alfred and so for
him Sinestro basically killed everyone
that he's ever known in love and so what
he does is he swears a blood vandetta
now the story initially comes to an end
it's really not a full-fledged thing we
don't really see what happens in the
final event between Batman as a Green
Lantern and Sinestro instead what
happens is he basically takes off you
know he says I'm going to create a grave
using my ring for Alfred pennyworth I'm
going to create a monument of swords and
with the Flash and Superman and Wonder
Woman Left Behind they initially say hey
look man like like you need to stay here
you have to teach us how to be Green
Lanterns and Batman says no he says I'm
going after Sinestro I'm going to find
Sinestro I'm going to kill him and uh
I'm going you know that's that's what
I'm that's what's going to happen that's
what's going to take place here and so
he basically leaves Superman Wonder
Woman and Flash on Earth as Green
Lanterns to figure out how to be
lanterns to figure out how to uh protect
the world on their own as best as they
can and so ultimately the other Green
Lanterns that were sent to capture Bruce
Wayne are recalled by the Guardians of
the universe and we learn that this was
all part of the Guardians plan that by
putting Batman and putting Sinestro
against one another that Sinestro would
likely uh create a situation whereby it
would instill a drive in Bruce Wayne to
ensure his destruction and so in effect
it would basically allow the Guardians
of the universe to get rid of Sinestro
in his totality by having one of the
Green Lanterns inspired to do it simply
because of the actions of Sinestro
himself but with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end
again this is this is a Kind of a Funny
situation you know to see that the uh
different members of the Justice League
become you know Green Lanterns to see
Batman becoming the Green Lantern it's
crazy um it's
cool but I would very much like to see
what happens in the followup I'd like to
know I'd like I'd like to see this great
big huge Grand PBA you know final
conflict between Batman as a Green
Lantern and Sinestro I'd like to know
where it goes but if you guys are new
here to Comics explain make sure you
guys drop a like and make sure you guys
hit the Subscribe button to become part
of the Rob core and uh yeah don't forget
to leave a comment down below giving us
a new oath and uh posting who your Green
Lantern is and I will catch you all
later
[Music]
peace